Hi, I'm Chet Haas, an engineer
the Android team at Google.
So, I did a "DevBytes" recently
talking about
anticipation and overshoot,
principles from cartoon
animation that could be
applied to some user
interfaces as well.
We also talked about this in our
Google I/O talk called the
Moving Experience.
You may want to check that out
for more information on some
of these principles.
But I wanted to go a little
bit further into these
principles of anticipation
and overshoot today
in a different demo.
So let's take a look.
So as I click on the
button, you'll
notice a couple of things.
One is, it reacts to
my press itself.
And then, as I let go of the
button, then it springs over
to the other side
of the screen.
So press sort of skews over the
left, and then shoots over
the right, and then wobbles a
bit to settle down into place.
So that's the demo, pretty
awesome, let's take
a look at the code.
So first of all, we want to
figure out how to actually
draw something like this.
There is new skew property.
There is no wobble and wiggle
property on a view.
So we need to do this
manually by altering
the Canvas of a view.
So you don't typically
override Draw.
And if you do, very important,
you have to call super.draw
because we do things internally
that flags and
state that you should
not skip.
Having said that, it's
OK to override Draw.
And in some cases,
you have to.
In particular, in this case, I
want to change the way the
view is actually drawn.
So I need to alter the Canvas
that it's drawn with.
So the way you do that is by
overriding Draw and then
altering the Canvas
and passing that
after the super class.
So when there is this skew
value, which is going to be
animated or changed between zero
and one, then we're going
to change the Canvas itself.
We're going to translate
around here, which is
basically going to set the
right center around which
we're actually going
to do the skew.
Then we're going to skew the
object to sort of give it
this, shift it to the right
or the left look.
And then we're going to call
super.draw and just say, OK,
now draw your button.
Now that I've completely mucked
with your Canvas, go
ahead and draw.
Meanwhile, here's how one
of the animations works.
So run press anim gets called
when we actually press down on
the button.
And that works by using an
object animator, which is
going to animate this property
called skewX on this object.
So I've defined the properties
setter called set skewX, and I
can use an object animator
to animate that arbitrary
property on my object.
And I'm going to animate it
between 0.5 and negative 0.5
And I'm going to set
a particular
duration for that thing.
And so it's going to be awfully
long as it rears back.
And this is the anticipation
element of this animation is
that it's going to rear back
before moving forward.
You can think of this button
as one of those old cartoon
characters that's going to run
forward, but, before they do
that, they're going to rear
back so that they get all
positioned and ready to do it.
That's effectively what I wanted
the button to do here.
And then I'm going to
set interpolator, so
it starts very fast.
I'm going to click
on the button.
It's going to quickly start into
the animation and then
slow down as it gets to the
end, sort of giving that
tension feel as it gets
to its extreme point.
And then we start
the animation.
If we look at the motion
handler, so I handle touch
events directly here because I
want to know when I'm inside
and outside the button so that I
can disable the animation if
they unclick when
it's outside--
all that stuff.
And I also want it to handle the
perform press operation.
And I want to handle
the up animation.
So when they've actually
pressed, then we perform our
click animation.
And the click animation
is going to
animate across the screen.
And then it's going to animate
the skew to the other side.
This is an overshoot
element where I
want it to stop suddenly.
But if it's an organic element,
like this sort of
skewy, squishy button that I've
defined, then all of it
can't stop at the same time
because that's very unnatural.
Instead, you're going to stop
the button, and then part of
it's going to carry on because
that's what gravity, and
inertia, and motion does
to our bodies, right?
So the bottom of it's going
to stop, and the top is
going to carry on.
And then it's going to wiggle
back and forth.
So it's going to overshoot back
to its original starting
location and then eventually
look like a normal button.
So if we take a look at the
click anim, here's where we
actually launch the
animations.
So here, we're going
to set up the--
if we hadn't run the full
anticipation animation yet,
we're going to hurry up and
finish that one up before we
actually launch the
moving animation.
Now, we're going to move the
thing across the screen.
This is going to animate a
translation x property on the
view, from wherever it is, on
the left or the right, to the
other side of the screen.
We're going to set an
interpolator of a linear
interpolator.
This is an interpolator
that I defined above.
This is an important point--
I would never use linear
interpolation on a movement
because it looks totally fake.
Instead, people, things, in our
real world accelerate into
motion and decelerate
out of it.
And that's a very
natural-feeling motion for
user interfaces as well.
However, in this particular
case, the effects that I
wanted was for the anticipation
to be the sort of
accelerating into this, and
then I want the motion to
start immediately.
When you unpress the button,
I want that button to start
immediately and move very
quickly across the screen.
And I want it to very quickly
stop on the other side of the
screen because that's where I
wanted the follow through
motion of the button actually
overshooting where it was and
then wobbling back
to the start.
So interpolating linearly is
totally appropriate here
because we're basically
accelerating into it with the
anticipation, and we're
decelerating out of it with
the overshoot animation on
the other side of it.
So linear animation, unusually
for a movement, and then we
wanted to find the
animation for the
other side of the screen.
So it's skewed over
to the left.
What we want is, when it reaches
the right hand side of
the screen, we want it to skew
back over to the right but
overshoot and then we want
it to wobble back to
where it was before.
So this is the skew animation
to go to the other side.
And we're going to do a quick
decelerator, so I wanted to
very quickly slow down from the
speed that it had from the
linear motion, linear
interpolator that I had before
in the previous animation.
And then I want it to wobble.
And the wobble is
going to again
animate the skew property.
And it's going to use this
overshoot interpolator, which
will end up at the final
value, but it'll
overshoot it first.
So that's exactly the
effect I wanted is--
we've overshot to the right and
now I want it to wobble
back past the stopping point and
then eventually end up at
the stopping point.
We use an animator set to do
these things sequentially.
So we're going to play all the
animations in sequence.
We're going to move the button,
skew past for the
overshoot, and then wobble back
to the starting position,
the normal position,
for the button.
And then we're going
to play it.
And that is it.
Thanks.